when we say changer base law right
people who were in my um who are in my
semester course my elective course last
year well no I kind of have this
love-hate relationship with the word law
when it refers to maths because kind of
like when I think of war it's kind of
what we've decided about how things
should run now what's the you know you
should drive on this side of the road
and you should pay these kind of taxes
and so on right and they're made up but
people but it not as in science laws are
nothing like that
it's just kind of the nature of things
as we discover them and how we try to
articulate that right so before we dive
into this just to get their heads in the
right space stick your hands up we have
a lot of log laws we already know from
the index laws so some want to give me
suggestion was once a lot we should have
at least four or five on top of our
heads
so we'll give you the easy one yeah by
the way that's exactly the way I pretty
much the way I said I tend to read these
as log base a of M of M if you remember
what we were saying about Mike my
metaphor for understand what logs are
about right you say the size of
something is its right to the power of
its time right so this is how big it's
going to be at a given growth rate so
when you convert this into a log
equation it's going to be log base the
base to stay the same are all s equals T
right so the idea is that you've got
this whole thing on the left hand side
is actually a period of time right and
you're growing at a certain rate and
you're getting to a certain size so all
of that size is what I'm sorry
all right good that's one it has its
reverse what's it service
they say off him good good money is
instead of addition of times right when
you're dividing you're taking the
difference between your times right okay
excellent someone else give me another
one who doesn't say yes
yeah okay excellent
what's the amount of time it takes to be
the size you already are answer you
already that size so no man tunnel I
can't zero so one give me another one
log base a is one how long does it take
to get to be eight times bigger than
what I am if I'm going at a rate of a
and the answer is one time period okay
another one aside to get to the trick
humans now what with powers powers like
this what shall I add to this ^ you can
call it anything you like I suppose if I
call it n where's that power going to go
out the front right now we didn't
explore this one before they're really
it's just a special case of this one
it's just a special case of the first
one can you see that right can you see
why that works think back in terms of
time right if you want it to grow at
such a such a rate and be that times
bigger you're gonna have to do it that
many times to grow to that point right I
can't that looks pretty good doesn't it
yeah okay all right let's let's do the
change of base law cuz they're pretty
much okay so here's the idea that if you
have some time period expression in some
growth rate right we can change it to be
in terms of from some other growth rate
using the change of base law in fact the
base is really the growth rate right we
have a fraction
thanks for clapping right okay who
remembers it somebody hasn't said
anything yet yes I shall we go okay all
right all right so so you've got the B
at the top and at the bottom so that's
how you remember the position of the VMA
right now what do you feel in here for
the bases and the answer is anything
you'd like okay so for instance the
standard way that this is written he's
gonna see it just means you know some
other number okay it's worth mentioning
at this point this is a good enough time
to say it as any that there are some
conventions for how to write different
logs like if I written it without a
letter there if I just written this okay
this has a meaning as well but it's a
bit tricky which is why I'm making a
special note of it if you see this
anywhere except your calculator anywhere
except for your calculator then when you
don't see a base there's a base implied
namely if it's anywhere except your
calculator the base that's implied is a
right now we'll get into e very soon
it's a very important number as you
might be able to imagine it's implied
and another way of writing a base e you
don't even throw it away my way is my
favorite way is with L n the N stands
for natural and why is a the natural
number to be the base of a log so we'll
explore that okay now I said anywhere
except for your calculator if it is on
your calculator and there's an easy way
to remember this by the way but I'll
show you in a second if it is on your
calculator and there's no number what
base is implied it's a base 10 now
that's for two reasons not well what if
you reach for your calculator now
do this get your calculator out and the
easy way to remember that on your
calculator it means base 10 and nowhere
else is because when you look at your
log button on your calculator right and
you can press unit log of five or
something like that and sure enough it
comes up it looks like this with no base
when you look above the button that says
log it says 10 to the power off so 10 is
the base right 10 is the radar which is
growing okay or whatever it is so that's
the first reason that you can either do
remember on a calculator its base ten I
might even write that this is calculator
only if you see it written in textbook
or in an exam or anywhere else
it means base eight the other one reason
to remember that it's base 10 is because
um what kind of calculator is this I can
say name right okay the brand is Cassie
but broadly speaking the category of
calculators is it's a scientific
calculator now what base are scientists
interested in because they use
scientific notation answer base 10
that's what scientific notation uses so
so that's how I remember that on the
calculator that's what I'm using
hopefully that's enough cues for you not
to confuse it anymore